women's health research at Yale funded a
pilot project in my laboratory and it
actually was a collaboration with dr.
Alessandro sandton who's in the
department of obstetrics and gynecology
Alessandro is an expert in ovarian
cancer and has long been trying to find
new ways to treat ovarian cancer
particularly that subset of ovarian
cancer that is resistant to most drugs
and and this is a common form of ovarian
cancer unfortunately and in my
laboratory we developed methods for
delivering drugs to to tumors more
effectively and this involves embedding
the drug molecules into very tiny
particles called nanoparticles and and
then decorating these nanoparticles so
that they recognize tumors and avoid all
other cells in the body and so the
Women's Health Research at Yale pilot
program allowed us to do the first
experiments in combining our two
interests to find new treatments for
ovarian cancer
there are two things that are exciting
about this this time for someone that's
doing the kind of research that I am one
is that we know a lot more about cancer
than we did before and so one has a lot
more ways to approach treating cancer
the other exciting thing is that in the
field of biomedical engineering we've
developed new tools and the tools that
we've developed our very small particles
particles that are the size of viruses
but are made of safe components that are
entirely synthetic we've learned how to
make these tiny particles and to
encapsulate chemotherapy drugs in them
and the advantage to that is that we can
make particles that will carry these
drugs specifically into the cells where
the drug is needed and they'll avoid
normal tissue this allows you to deliver
chemotherapy right at the site of action
and not have the side effects that one
normally associate with chemotherapy
as a result of the early studies that we
were able to do with funding from
women's health research at Yale we were
able to get some early results and write
an application to the National
Institutes of Health which was funded at
a larger amount I think the most
important thing that we've found so far
is that we could take nanoparticles the
kind of nanoparticles we learned how to
make in the laboratory and we could tune
them so that they can selectively find
ovarian cancer cells and we've proven
this in in laboratory models the
practical value of what we've been
studying is that we we hope that this
will lead to new treatments for ovarian
cancer in our work so far has been very
promising and one of the things that
we've been very careful about as we've
proceeded is to select materials that
are known to be safe in constructing our
nanoparticles so that as we get good
results in a laboratory we can rapidly
translate that into new treatments for
women